[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادها الليله معكم عبد
القادر عياد في الوقت الذي احدثه تبقى
واحداث وتطور اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من
العالم هذه صور من نيويورك وجلسه مفتوحه
من الامم المتحده للتصويت على مشروع قرار
روسي لتشكيل لجنه التحقيق في مزاعم موسكو
بان واشنطن وكيف يعني
بموجب اتفاقيه الاسلحه البيولوجيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد تصدر لكهود النتائج شبه النهائيه
للانتخابات ب 65 بقعدا تحالفون نتنياهو مع
جماعات اليمين المتطرف يثير الجدل
اسرائيليا ودوليا
الى 55 بقعدا ويتمار بن جري عقبه المحتمله
في تعامل واشنطن مع اي حكومه قد يشكلها
لتنياهو
في ختام القمه العربيه اعلان الجزائري
يؤكد على مركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه ودعم
حصول فلسطين على العضويه الكامله في الامم
المتحده تجديد على رفض التدخلات الخارجيه
وعلى التمسك بمبدا الحلول العربيه للمشاكل
العربيه ووزير الخارجيه السعوديه
للاستضافه بلاده للقمه المقبله
مع اعلان اردوغان اتفاقه مع بوتن على
استئناف تصدير الحبوب الرئيس الروسي يقول
انه تلقى ضمانات امنيه اوكرانيه رسميه
لعدم استخدام الممرات الانسانيه في
العمليات العسكريه وكيف تشير الى زياده
عمليه التفتيش لتسريع حركه ملاحه سفود
الحبوب
واشنطن ترحب في العمل بالاتفاق والمندوبه
الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده تقول فيه
لقاء مع الجزيره ان روسيا باتت معزوله
بعد تسعه ايام من المفاوضات في جنوب
افريقيا وبوساطه الاتحاد الافريقي الحكومه
الاثيوبيه وجبه التكراي توقعان على اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار واستئناف وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه الخارجيه الامريكيه ترحب
بالاتفاق وتقول انه خطوه مهمه نحو تحقيق
السلام في تقرير
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد كنا قد
ناقشنا معكم موضوع طبعا من انصتنا الرقم
روسيا مع تركيا على استئناف المشاركه في
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود بعد
حصول موسكو على ضمانات خطيه من كيف بعدم
استغلال ممرات الحبوب عسكري
بس تطلعي ايه رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم الى
اي مدى سيصمد اتفاق تصديري الحبوب 60%
راوا انه سيصمد لحاجه الاطراف اليه بينما
40% قالوا انه سيكون هشام وفقا للتطورات
الميدانيه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا في بنصتنا الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهر على الشاشه
تابعونا في الحصاد هذه الليله ايضا
في البرازيل بعد فوز لولا دا سيلفا انصاري
يحتجون ويقطعون طرقات
[موسيقى]
نتائج الشبه النهائيه لانتخابات الكنيست
اغلبيه كبيره لمعسكر اقصى اليمين بزعامه
بنيامين ياهو بحصوله على 65 مقعدا بينما
لم يحصل معسكر تغيير بزعامه الا على 55
مقعدا منها 10 مقاعد للحزبين العربيين
القائمه العربيه الموحده وتحالف الجبهه
الديمقراطيه والعربيه للتغيير وعززت هذه
الانتخابات موقع اثمار بن غفير زعيم
التيار اليميني المتطرف وهو ما يطرح
تساؤلات عن مستقبل العلاقه مع الفلسطينيين
وكيفيه طاعات المجتمع الدولي مع حكومه هي
الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل
مين كولاميد جاميني طمطوم
كي يعود الى الحكم لكنه حصل على اكثر من
ذلك ليس بعدد المقاعد فحسب بل بتمكنه من
تشكيل قاعده لاتلاف النيابيا مستقرا
ومتجانس سياسيا وعقائديا
يضم احزاب اليمين المتطرف واحزاب
المتدينين هم حلفاؤه ليس فقط في تشكيل
التوليفه الحكوميه بل بتحقيق هدفه
الاساسيه من عودته للسلطه الغاء محاكمته
بقضايا الفساد المتهم بها
ليس نتنياهو وحده الفائزه في الانتخابات
في الرابح الاكبر هو اثمار بن كبير زعيم
التيار اليمني المتطرف فقد تضاعفت قوته
بشكل كبير وهو الذي بنى شعبيته على كراهيه
العرب وطرد الفلسطينيين من وطنهم بل قتلهم
بن كبير الذي لا يفوت فرصه لاقتحام المسجد
الاقصى والوصول الى مناطق احتكاك مع
الفلسطينيين
واشهاري سلاحه في وجههم انتقل منها مش
الخريطه الحزبيه الاسرائيليه الى صلبها
وتحول الى قوه مركزيه في الحكومه المقبله
كافه الحكومات الاسرائيليه يمينيه وعنصريه
الا ان ما جرى خطير جدا في الانتخابات
الاخيره صعود للفاشيه في اسرائيل ودخولها
للحكومه وهذه الفاشيه التي يمثلها
تمثل امتدادا لحزب كهانه الفاشي الذي يصنف
حكم حتى في اسرائيل باعتباره حزب الفاشيه
هذا امر خطير بالاضافه الى ان المستوطنين
المستعمرين في اسرائيل اصبحوا قوه سياسيه
مقرره في الحكومه الاسرائيليه وسياساتها
وفي مقابل صعود اليمين المتطرف تراجعت
احزاب محسوبه على اليسار والوسط في مؤشر
اخر على جنوح الشارع الاسرائيلي نحو مزيدا
من التطرف تغيرات يرى الفلسطينيون داخل خط
الاخضر انها ستؤثر عليهم ايضا على الجميع
طبعا تحدي كبير اذا كان على المستوى ساحه
الفلسطينيه وايضا على مستوى الساحه
العربيه في الداخل ولكن يجب ان ننظر ايضا
الى جزئيه مهمه ان حكومه بهذا الشكل قد
تكون ايضا تواجه تساؤلات كثيره على
المستوى الدولي هنالك من يعتبر ان قد تكون
معزوله دوليا ولكن واضح انها تشكل التحدي
وتحدي كبير
وهذه التساؤلات المتعلقه بسيناريوهات تعات
المجتمع الدولي والاداره الامريكيه مع هذه
الحكومه ستجيب عنها الايام المقبله وان
كان نتنياهو بدا يتدارك الامر بتصويق نفسه
كمعتدلا في هذه الحكومه انهت هذه
الانتخابات الازمه السياسيه المتواصله في
اسرائيل منذ سنوات لكنها اظهرت كذلك ان
غالبيه الاسرائيليين قالوا نعم للتطرف
والعنصريه والفساد بانتخابهم رئيس حكومه
يحاكم بيتها من فساد جنائيه وهو ما يعكس
توجهات اسرائيل شعبيا وسياسيا
في المرحله القادمه
نجوان سمري الجزيره مدينه القدس
من غير المرجح ان تتعامل اداره مع العضو
المتطرف لكنيست اثمار
الذي يتوقع ان يتولى منصب وزاريا رفيعا في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وذكر الموقع ان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
ومستشاره الامن القومي الامريكي
جيكسوليفان المحايا الى احتمال اعاده
العمل مع بنك فير وغيره من المتطرفين
اليمنيين وذلك خلال اجتماعهما مع الرئيس
الاسرائيلي الاسبوع الماضي كما قال الموقع
عند الاداره الامريكيه قلقه من الخطاب
العنصري لبن فير وحزبه ومواقفه تجاه
الفلسطيني
ينضم الينا من نيويورك
المبعوث الامريكيه السابق لعمليه السلام
في الشرق الاوسط وكذلك ضيفي من نابلس
الدكتور رائد ابو بدويه استاذ القانون
الدولي والعلاقات الدوليه في الجامعه
العربيه الامريكيه اهلا بكم
عن تصورك لشكل العلاقه بين واشنطن وتل
ابيب في ظل هذه الحكومه وماذا اذا كان من
ضمن هذه الحكومه اليمنيه اليمنيه المتطرفه
المنتظره ان يكون من ضمنها السيد بنغفير
على راس وزاره السياديه
علينا ان نرى حقيقه ماذا تتمخض عنه الامور
وماذا سيفعل نتنياهو اعتقد ان هناك
امكانيه ان يكون امامه
الطريق وعرى خاصه اذا ما حاول البعض ان
يدفع
باتجاه سياسه استيطان شديده وزياده
الاستيطان هذا لابد وان
يسيره التوترا مع اداره
لكن ايضا هناك قضيه ايران
قد لا يمتلك الكثير مما يقول عن هذا الملف
لكنه بالتاكيد صار لديه ما يقول واما
احتمال بان الكونجرس اذا ما وقع بايدي
الجمهوري معروف
ان هو مهاره السياسيه في استغلال العلاقه
معهم اذا هناك احتمال ان يكون هناك توتر
في العلاقه بسبب هذه الامور الدكتور رائد
ابو بدويه نحن امام اي همم حكومه قادمه في
اسرائيل في ظل هذه
النتائج سواء تعلق الامر بما وعد به
نتنياهو اا من صوتوا له او ما يتعلق في
وجود اسماء على شاكله بنجير
يعني واضح انه هذه الحكومه تكون اكثر
حكومه يمنيه متطرفه همم منذ 48 حتى اليوم
ولكن مدى انعكاس همم هذا الحكومه وتشكيل
هذه الحكومه بهذا اليمين المتطرف على
العلاقه مع العالم وعلى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه باعتقد انه متوقف على ثلاث
اسباب رئيسيه بسبب الاول اللي هو مواقف
نفسه ماذا ستكون همم قضايا الاستيطان من
جهات تجاه قضيه حل الدور الثاني من جهه
اخرى واتجاه العلاقه والاتفاق النمو مع
ايران كما سبق وتكلم السفير همم فيما تعلل
هذا السبب الاول السبب الثاني او اعتقد
العامل الاخر اللي سيلعب دور اللي هي
طبيعه او الوزاره نفسها التي
سيتسلمها في نفسه هل هي همم
وزاره السياديه همم بعد دوله في العمل ام
هي اا وزاره خدماتيه اعتقد برده هذا بيلعب
دور ثاني والعامل الثالث ايضا باعتقد اللي
هي نتائج النصفيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في حال اا بقاء سيطره
الديمقراطيين على الكونجرس الامريكي
باعتقد انه هذا من شان انه يوتر العلاقه
اكثر م- مع اسرائيل في ظل الحكومه يمنيه
اما اذا همم فقد فقد حزب ديموقراطيه سيطره
على على الكونجرس وعلى الاغلبيه باعتقد
انه هذا من شان انه يخفف من حده التوتر في
العلاقه معي همم حكومه اسرائيليه قادمه
وننساش ان المشكله مش بس يعني هو هو بن
غفير زاد المشكله ولكن المشكله اصلا هي
سابقه من ايام عهد همم باراك اوباما ولا
تنياهو وهمم وضع ازمه على علاقات مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طيب ثلاث
عوامل هن اهم اهم ثلاث
دكتور اسال عنه السفير مارتن اين كما نقله
موقع اكسيوس نقل له اعضاء باريزون في
الاداره الحاليه الامريكيه الى الرئيس
الامريكي بان ربما قد تجد صعوبه في
التعامل مع حكومه من ضمنها السيد بن جرير
ما الذي يعني كلمه وجود صعوبه
باختصار وتكرنت
طويل في
التعصب والعنصريه
والمواقف المتشدده والمتطرفه ضد
الفلسطينيين وطبعا هذا ما تتحدث عنه
الاداره بالضروره لو ان مثل هذه المواقف
التي يعبر عنها تصبح
مواقف للحكومه نتنياهو هذا شكله مشكله لو
ان برك اعطي موقعا يتصرف فيه للتعامل مع
الولايات المتحده واداراتها اعتقد ربما
الاداره قد لا تقبل التعامل معه هو ربما
هذا هذه المخاوف ستنقل الى نت ياهو
ليفهم بانه لن يكون من
الصواب وضع بين قفير في اي موقع قد يعارض
العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده للخطا دكتور
رائد هل من مصلحه نتنياهو ان يجد صيغه
الماء لان لا يكون بن كثير من ضمن
الوزارات السياديه ام انا حساب الباديه او
تختلف
لا لا اعتقد انه نتنياهو سرحت نائل الحمله
الانتخابيه بانه بنغفر سيتولى وزاره وسرح
كمان انه لا يقبل بالاملاءات من جهات
خارجيه وهو يقصد الوقت المتحده في موضوع
وزاره وتولي الوزارات ولكنه ااه في نفس
الوقت اليوم بيصرح بطريقه ووصل رساله الى
الامريكان باعتقد انها رساله تهدئه او
تطنينات الامريكان اللي قال انه سنتجنب
المغامرات التي لا طا الى من وراءها
وباعتقد ان هذه كانت الرساله لطمئنه
الجانب الامير تركي ولكن المشكله مش فقط
في بين غفير باعتقد المشكله يعني راح تكون
في سياسات نتنياه نفسه ومواقفه تجاه
القضايا المفصليه الخلافيه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
شكرا لك من نابلس يا دكتور رائد ابو بدويه
استاذه قانون الدولي والعلاقات الدوليه في
الجامعه العربيه الامريكيه وكذلك للسفير
مارتن اند ديك المبعوث الامريكي السابق
لعمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط
على اي حال لمزيد من الوقوف على طبيعه
شركاءه الياهو في التحالف الذي يتم الحديث
عنه سيكون بعد قليل ضمن فقره في المتابعه
[موسيقى]
انتهت في الجزائر القمه العربيه في دورتها
الحاديه والثلاثين ببيان الختامي شدد على
دعم فلسطين وتعزيز الامن القومي العربي
ومكافحه الارهاب ومواجهه الاسلام فوبيا
هذا هو اعلن الامين العام للجامي العربي
ان القمه المقبله ساتا عقد في السعوديه
اعلان الجزائر اختتمت اعمال القمه العربيه
الحاديه والثلاثين بعد يومين من
الاجتماعات على مستوى القاده
البيان الختامي لم يخرج عن مالوف بيانات
القمم السابقه وبنوودها المكرره حول
مركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه وتفعيل العمل
العربي المشترك وحمايه الامن القومي
العربي مضافا الى ذلك المستجد من القضايا
والوقائع وما اكفرها في عالم عربي مثقال
بالماذق والازمات
اكد اعلان الجزائر على دعم توجه دوله
فلسطين للحصول على العضويه الكامله في
الامم المتحده
ومساندته تحركاتها القانونيه لمحاسبه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على جرائمه كما طالب
البيان برفع الحصار المفروض على قطاع غزه
وتحقيق المصالحه الفلسطينيه
تضمنت البنود ايضا الدعوه الى حل الازمه
ليبيه وتنظيم انتخابات في اسرع وقت ممكن
والى ايجاد حل سياسيا في سوريا يضمن وحده
اراضيها وبشان الازمه اليمنيه طالب البيان
الختامي بتجديد الهدنه وانجاز تسويه
سياسيه شامله بعيدا عن التدخلات الخارجيه
كما اكد اعلان الجزائر دعم قطر في استضافه
كاس العالم ورفض حملات التشويه التي تتعرض
لها دوليا اعاد البيان التذكره بالموقف
العربي المحايد من الحرب في اوكرانيا وثمن
قرار اوبك بلس لضمان استقرار اسواق الطاقه
العالميه
قمه لم الشمل التي التامت بعد ثلاث سنوات
من الانقطاع بسبب جائحه كورونا تخللتها
قبل الاختتام رهانات شتته بينها مناشده
رئيس الحكومه اللبنانيه نجيب ميقاتي
مساعده عربيه لاخراج لبنان من ازماته
ومطالبه الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
بتشكيل لجنتين وزاريتين عربيتين تتحركان
دوليا لفضح ممارسات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وشرح الروايه الفلسطينيه وقد لاقت تلك
التطلعات وغيرها استجابات متفاوته في
البيان الختامي ليكون العرب مره اخرى امام
تحدي تفعيل قراراتهم ولو بحدها الادنى قبل
انعقاد القمه المقبله في السعوديه
هذا ما قاله وزير الخارجيه الجزائريه
رمثان العمامره ان القمه العربيه الحاديه
والثلاثين التي ختمت اليوم في الجزائر
حققت اهم اهدافها بفتح افاق واعده من اجل
تعزيز العام العربي المشترك واولويه
القضايا العربيه الجامعه على حساب القضايا
الخلفيه
الرغبه في فتح افاق واعد للعمل العربي
المشترك
وكذلك
لجعل الجوامع
تطغى وتاخذ الاولويه على كل الجوانب التي
من الممكن ان تحمل في طياتها بذور خلافات
وامور من شان ان تؤدي الى تصدع العمل
بينما المراد هو جمع الكلمه ورس الصفوف
اكد وزير الخارجيه المغربي ناصر البوريتو
عند العمل العربيه المشترك لا يمكن ان
يكون مرتبط فقط بالقمم رغم اهميتها وعذب
في مقابله مع الجزيره تراجع العمل العربي
المشترك الى غياب الارادات السياسيه
واليات العمل للتعاطي مع القضايا الملح
مقاربه جلاله الملك هي ان القمم
احداث مهمه ولكنها لا تختزل لعمل العربي
المشترك العمل العربي المشترك لا يمكن لا
يمكن ان يصير فقط بايقاع القيمه
يجب ان يكون هاجس 365 يوم في السنه
باش نقيسه العمل فكانت ثلاث سنين ونصف هذه
على الاخر
ولكن
ما هو اقتصادي واجتماعي كذلك مهم
واشار وزير الخارجيه المغربي ناصر موريتا
الى ان القضيه التي شهدت اجماعا في القمه
العربيه دون سواها هي القضيه الفلسطينيه
واوضح في مقابله مع الجزيره ان التدخلات
الاجنبيه في القضايا العربيه وتطوير عمل
الجامعه العربيه تطلبان مراعاه كل الاراء
افق تعبيره
الدوليه
للوصول الى توافقات التوافقات اساسيه او
ثاني باش نطبقها لان يمكن يكون قرارات
الاقليه والقرارات كتقسم
الدول العربيه
والقضايا كانت مهمه يعني همم
القضيه الفلسطينيه
في القضايا العربيه همم تطوير عمل الجامعه
العربيه القضايا مثل ليبيا مثل همم وغير
هيك ممكن تحتاج الى تخدمي على الاعتبار كل
الاراء
واضاف وزير الخارجيه المغربي ناصر البريطا
ان الوفد المغربي لم يتلقى تاكيدا منذ
وصوله الى الجزائر بشان ترتيبات للقاءات
ثنائيه مع الجانب الجزائري واكد في مقابله
مع الجزيره ان العائله المغربي قدم دعوه
مفتوحه للرئيس الجزائري لزياره المغرب في
اي وقت وذلك للدخول في حوار البناء وصريح
على اعلى مستوى حول العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين
بالقنوات
غير مباشره تسالنا عن هناك ترتيبات لقاءات
ثنائي اكثر من ثلاث ايام ولم نتلقى تاكيد
حولها اي ترتيبات لشيء ثنائي ثانيا البلد
المضيف كانت عنده الامكانيه
الى المغرب مباشره مع الوفد المغربي او
عند قنوات غير مباشره للتواصل للاخبار
بيضه ثالثا العلاقه المغربيه الجزائريه
ولقاء على هذه المستوى بين جلاله الملك
وفخامه الرئيس
اكثر من خطاب كانت موقف جلاله الملك واضح
حوار شامل
في الجزائر لاسباب ربما ضغط الوقت او
لاسباب مرتبطه بقنوات التواصل
فشلت الملك اعطت تعليمات باش انها تكون
دعوه مفتوحه لفخامه الرئيس لزياره المغرب
في اي وقت
والدخول في حوار على على مستوى حول
العلاقات الثنائيه حوار بناء حوار شامل
حوار صريح وحوار ان شاء الله اللي يؤدي
الى نتائج ايجابيه
[موسيقى]
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الحبوب واضافه الوزاره انه بفضل الامم
المتحده وتركيا تمكنت روسيا من الحصول على
ضمانات مكتوبه من الجانب الاوكراني هذا
واوضح الكريم لان بوست واشترطت للعوده
لصفقه الحبوب السماح بمرور منتجاتها ووقف
استخدامك المره الامنه لاهداف عسكري
من جانبه قال الرئيس الروسي ان بلاده
تحتفظ بالحق في الانسحاب من اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب في حال انتهكت اوكرانيا الضمانات
واضاف بوتين ان موسكو طالبه كيا بتقديم
ضمانات بانها لم تكرر الهجمات في البحر
الاسود واوضح بوتين انه في حال انسحاب
بلاده من الصفقه فانها لن تمنع تصدير
الحبوب من اوكرانيا الى تركيا في المستقبل
هذا وكان رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان قد
اعلن انه اتفق مع الرئيس الروسي بلدي
ميرفتين على ان الحبوب ستذهب الى افريقيا
اولا
لو كانت وزاره البناء التحتيه الاخرانيه
قالت انه خلال اليومين الماضيين عبرت خمسه
عشره او عبرت 15 فلسفينا محمله بالحبوب
الاوكرانيه ممر البحر الاسود كما عادت
سفينتان فارغتان الى الموانئ الاخرانيه
لتحميل الحبوب وعشره الوزاره الاخرانيه
الى مغادره ثلاث سفن امس محمله ب 85,000
طن من المنتجات الزراعيه بينما استقبلت
الموانئ الاخرانيه سفينتين للتحميل واضافت
الوزاره ان جهود تركيا والامم المتحده
اسفلت عن زياده عدد مجموعات التفتيش في
مضيق الفسفور التركي الى 10 مجموعات
لتسريع عمليه تفتيش السفن القادمه
والمغادره في اطار مبادره الحبوب
يقضي اتفاق الحبوب في مدينه اسطنبول في ال
22 من تموز الماضي بين روسيا واوكرانيا
برعايه تركيه اميه بان تكون اليه تنفيذه
على النحو التالي قبل انطلاق السفن من
الموانئ الاوكرانيه على البحر الاسود يتم
تفتيشها من ممثلين اتراك واوكرانيين ومن
الامم المتحده تسلك السفن ممرات امنه من
الالغام في المياه الاوكرانيه يدل عليها
خبراء اوكرانيون تتم متابعه هذه السفن عبر
الممرات المتفق عليها لضمان عدم تعرضها
لاي هجوم سواء من البحر او من الجوي او من
البر يعمله مركز التنسيق في اسطنبول على
مراقبه المغادره السفن فنيا عبر الاقطار
الصناعيه والانترنت وسائل الاتصال الاخرى
ويقوم بجميع انشطته بالتنسيق مع الدول
المعنيه والامم المتحده
عند وصول السفن الى مضيق البسفور التركي
يتم توزيعها على الموانئ المختلفه بما
يراعي سعه السفينه وسعه الميناء وهناك يتم
تفتيشها من قبل الاطراف الاربعه تركيا
وروسيا واوكرانيا والامم المتحده وبعدها
تتحرك الى وجهتها الاخيره بعد عوده السفن
فارغه يتم فحصها في الموانئ التركيه
للتاكدين من خلوها من اي مواد غير مرغوب
فيها ثم تعود الى اوكرانيا في التاسع
والعشرين من اكتوبر الماضي علقت روسيا
مشاركتها في اتفاق الحبوب بعد هجوم تعرض
له اسطورها في البحر الاسود لاحقا وبعد
جهود تركيا وافقت موسكو على استئناف العمل
بالاتفاق بعد اعلانها الحصول على ضمانات
مكتوبه
بعدم استخدام الممرات الامنه لاغراض
عسكريه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من انقره
المحلل السياسي في مركز سيتا
لابحاث سيد اوسوك
هل في هذا الاتفاق
الجديد ما يضمنوا ديمومته ما يضمن الا
يتكرر مره اخرى ويتم منع تصدير الحبوب
طبعا
سيستمر من دون تعطير لعده اسباب لاننا
حاليا نعلم ان
الجانب الاوكراني
مكتوبه طالبه بها اجانب الروسي
بانهم لم يخرج عن نطاق اعتبار هذا مرات
انسانيه لتستخدم لاغراض عسكريه وغير ذلك
اذا هذه الصعوبه قد تم تجاوزها لكن ما زال
امامنا صعوبات لدينا تاريخ مهم وهو تاريخ
التاسع عشر من نوفمبر والذي ينتهي فيه
مفعول الاتفاقيه لا ندري هل ان في
الروس سيوقفون النهائيا اتفاق في الثامن
عشر من نوفمبر ام يستمرون او يجددونها
لهذا السبب في المستقبل حتى لو انسحبت
روسيا من الاتفاق
سيسمحون على الاقل بنقل الحبوب الى تركيا
عن طريق تركيا هذا طبعا يعني اننا لا
نستطيع استبعاده توقف الاتفاق لكن هناك
فرصه في استمراره وما هو نقطه مهمه
حتى ولو انسحب الجانب الروسي فانه سيسمح
لتركيا
ان تصدر منتجاتها عن طريق همم تركيا
ما تفسير هذه النقطه
قصص سيدنا
الروس لن يتدخلوا او لن يوقفوا رساله
الشحنات عن طريق السفن تغادر الموارد
الموانئ
الاوكرانيه الى تركيا
لهذا الموضوع من اهميه وهو نقل الحبوب الى
بلدان العالم الثالث والتي هي بحاجه ماسه
وهنا تقبل نقطه مهمه لان هذه هي هي
البلدان التي هي بحاجه ماسه وايضا
ناروتو
مع مع اشكرك ضيفي من انقره
خانزرتك المحلل السياسي بمركز سيتا
للابحاث
اخذ مجلس الامن الاجتماعي غير رسمي بشان
الاحتجاجات في ايران نظمته كل من الولايات
المتحده والمانيا حيث تضمن عده ايحاطات
احداها للمقر الامميه الخاص الماليه بحاله
حقوق الانسان في ايران بعد هذه الجلسه
وقبل الحصاد اجريت مقابله مع السفيره
ليندا توماس جرين فيلد المندوب الامريكيه
لدى الامم المتحده وسالتها عن مخرجات
الجلسه وتطرقنا كذلك الى ملف الحرب في
اوكرانيا
هنا
العالم وايران وكذلك 15 دوله في مجلس
الامن يتحدثون بشان الوضع على الارض في
ايران اردنا ان تعلم الحكومه الايرانيه
انما تقوم به مدان واردنا ان نخاطب
المحتجين على الارض لكي يعلم انهم يحضون
بدعم العالم وهم يقاتلون ويناضلون من اجل
حقوقهم الانسانيه ازاء الهجمات الوحشي
يوتيوب
كامل استطعنا ان نسمع كل الدول ما يحدث
والسمع من المقرر الخاص التابعي للامم
المتحده وسمع ايضا من مؤسستين من المجتمع
المدني
عبرتا عن قرارات قويه ودعم للمحتجين
والمتظاهرين وكل من في القاعه عبر عن قلقه
تجاه الوضع في ايران
الشرقاوي
دعت الى مقاطعه هذه الجلسه بل واتهمتكم
بانكم تحاولون تسييسه هيئه انسانيه
ايران اطلقت هذه الادعاءات وارادت ان تدعو
الناس لعدم الحضور لكن القاعه كانت مليئه
وما صرحوا به ليس له اساس في الواقع
التظاهرات واضحه والصحافه تغطي ما تراه
على الارض ونسمع من المواطنين الايرانيين
عندما يستطيعون التواصل مع العالم الخارجي
وبالتالي الاهداف تحققت وانا غير مستغربه
من عدم تشجيع ايران على حضور الاجتماع
متحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه قبل ايام
قال بان واشنطن لم تتعلم من اخطائها
السابقه وانما تقوم به الان هو محاوله لان
تقدم ايران مزيد من التنازلات بما يتعلق
بالملف النووي الايراني
حاليا نحن لا نركز على موضوع الاتفاق
النووي تركيزنا على ان المتظاهرين يتعرضون
للهجوم ونركز على حقيقه ان الحكومه
الايرانيه تقدم السلاح للحكومه الروسيه في
هجومها غير المبرر على اوكرانيا وتستهدف
المدنيين وتدمر البنا التحتيه الرئيس كان
واضحا باننا لن نسمح لايران بالحصول على
السلاح النووي وباننا مستعدون لايجاد طرق
دبلوماسيه في المستقبل وهذا هو الموقف
الحالي
ولكن ايضا هنا ابقى لانقل ما يقوله
الايرانيون ايضا يقول بين يتهمونكم بان
هناك دعم مباشر من قبل واشنطن لما يجري في
الاحتجاجات في ايران وانكم بهذا الدعم
انما تريدون ان تضغط على الجانب الايراني
وانكم لم تتعلموا بدليل ان الجانب
الايراني واجه عقوباتكم بعقوبه المقابله
خرجوا بشكل فوري للاحتجاج على قتل فظيع
لشابه اعتقلتها شرطه الاخلاق وزجه بها في
السجن ثم اغمي عليها ثم توفيت المتظاهرون
خرجوا بدون اي علاقه مع الولايات المتحده
بل خرج لان الناس سئموا من وضع يمنع عليهم
ممارسه حرياتهم الامر لا يتعلق بالولايات
المتحده نحن نتعامل متظاهرين بالتاكيد لكن
هم من خرجوا ضد حكومتهم
في الجغرافيا مختلفه يتعلق الامر في
اوكرانيا ايضا اتهمتم الجانب الايراني
بتزويد روسيا بطائرات
مسيره ارجو ان تكون تسمعيني لي
بتزويد روسيا بطائرات مسيره الجانب
الايراني ينفي وبالتالي لماذا اسراركم على
ان طهران تزود روسيا بهذه الطائرات
ذلك ولكن هناك ادله ملموسه بانهم فعلوا
ذلك يقدمون الطائرات الى روسيا لا شك في
ذلك اطلاقا واي انكار من الجانب الايراني
هو مجرد اكاذيب نحن نعلم انهم يقدمون هذه
الاسلحه وباقيه العالم تعرف ذلك ايضا
عندما يتعلق الامر سفير اجري فيلد مشكله
بحجم ما يجري في اوكرانيا يعود التساؤل عن
دور هذه المنظمه منظمه الامم المتحده في
قضيه شائكه كهذه اين دور هذه المنظمه في
انهاء ما يجري في اوكرانيا
على هذا السؤال الامم المتحده كانت قويه
في ردها على الوضع في اوكرانيا مجلس الامن
دانا روسيا والجمعيه العامه وباكثر من 140
صوتا دانت روسيا وضمها لاراضا اخذتها من
اوكرانيا روسيا اصبحت معزوله في الامم
المتحده ايضا نتعامل مع دول اخرى في
العالم لمواصله الضغوط عليهم لدفهم لاتخاذ
القرار المناسب وهو سحب قوتهم من اوكرانيا
وانهائها هذه الحرب الشنيعه
ولكن عندما نتكلم عن الهيئات داخل الامم
المتحده تحديدا عن مجلس الامن اقوى هيئه
في هذه المنظمه هناك الفيتو وبالتالي
كيف يمكن لهذه المؤسسه وعلى راسها مجلس
الامن ان تكون حاسمه وفاعله في ملفك هذا
والفيتو موجود لدى مختلف الاطراف الفاعله
في هذا الملف
لا نستطيع ان نغير حقيقه ان روسيا لديها
حق الفيتوس ولكن نستطيع القول ان هذا
النقطه لا يعني ان لديها حق حجب اصواتي
اربعه عشر عضو في مجلس الامن كانوا بطرق
مختلفه ما قامت به روسيا لا يمكن للفيتو
ان يحجب صوت 140 دوله في الجمعيه العامه
ولا يمكن ان يضعوا بيته على حق الشعب
الاوكراني في الدفاع عن نفسه قد يكون
لديهم حق الفيتو ولكن هذا لا يحميهم من
العزله والادانه ثم
السفيره ليندا
المندوبه الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده
شكرا جزيلا لك
ينضم الينا من طهران الدكتور عباس خاميار
الدبلوماسي الايراني السابق دكتور عباس
سبعه معي هذه
المقابله عند سؤالها عن جلسه هذا اليوم
قالت في مقابل ما دعته ايران بمقاطعه هذه
الجلسه الحضور كان كثيفا في هذه الجلسه
واوصل صوتهم بكل قوه
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا سمعته الى
هذه المقابله لا اتصور احد في ايران
يستطيع ان يصدق المزاعم
الامريكيه
الايرانيون وحتى الشعوب العربيه
والاسلاميه والشعوب العالم باجماعه العالم
الحوري يعرف جيدا المجازر الامريكيه التي
ارتكبت ضد الشعوب الذاكره الايرانيه مليئه
بهذه العناوين همم انا اريد ان اؤكد بان
في عام 1950 همم هذه الامم المتحده بقياده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي التي وقفت
امام مشروع تامين النفط الايراني واعتبرته
همم يعني همم ضد السلام واا
يعني فرضت عقوبات على ايران في تلك الفتره
وعام 1953 قامت بانقلاب عسكري مع بري ضد
همم الدكتور محمد مصدق رئيس الوزراء
الوطني همم الدكتور مصدق لم يكن يملك
منظومه صاروخيه ولم يكن همم يحمل
ايدولوجيه ثوريه ولم يكن يحمل مشروع
النووي وانما كان يريد تامين النفط وهذا
الحد الادنى همم من المطالب الايرانيه
التي كان الدكتور عباس الدكتور محمد رغم
ما ذكرته الان من هذا ال- ال- التاريخ الا
تشكل ما تقوم به واشنطن الان ادوات ضغط
اضافيه حتى وان كانت من خلال الهيئات داخل
الامم المتحده قالت ايران بانه لا يجب
تاسيس هذه الهيئات الانسانيه
لا لم يكن لم تكن هناك يعني هيئات انسانيه
هذه اكاذيب ومزاعم في قمه كورونا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فرضت على ايران
حظر الدواء وحظر الادويه التي كانت بحاجه
اليها الاطفال في تلك الفتره العصيبه التي
لم تستطع ايران مباشره ان تصنع هذه
العقاقير التي شاهدناها فيما بعد التي
قامت بتصديرها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
همم الحقيقه هي التي يعني اسقطت الطائره
الايرانيه وعلامتها حدود 300 مسافر كان 66
منهم هؤلاء اطفال وهمم منحت همم
المجرم همم يعني بيسان همم الولايات
المتحده الامري هؤلاء لا اتصور بانهم
صادقون نحن والعالم الحر وكل دول المنطقه
اساسي
عفوا الم ننسى المجازر في افغانستان
والعراق ولبنان وسوريا وهنا في ايران على
مدى العقود الماضيه الوثائق الامريكيه
التي
نشرت من قبل الطلاب
المجموعات التي احتلت السفاره الامريكيه
هي خير الدليل
عباس
نقطه مهمه عند سؤالي لها فيما يتعلق
بالاتهامات واشنطن بالتورته فيما يجب
احتجاجاته في ايران قالت يجب التركيز على
ان ما يجري هو يعني فعل من قبل مواطنيننا
ايرانيين
نعم هذه هناك وثائق ستنشر هناك يعني هناك
صحيح في بعض الشباب خرجوا هذه مطالب ربما
يعتبروها يعني احقاق حقوقهم ولكن بالتاكيد
هناك النوات التي كانت تقوم بالعمليات
التخريبيه بحرق الاموال ومؤسسات الحكوميه
هذه كانت مرتبطه هناك بيانات نشرت في هذا
المجال وهناك وثائق واضحه ودامغه همم تشير
الى هذه الامور شكرا المره الاولى همم
للتدخل الامريكي في الشؤون الايرانيه
وهناك كانت تدخلات سابعه سابقه في مواقع
مختلفه وفي العالم اجمعه دكتور عباس
الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه السابقه
وقعت الحكومه الاثيوبيه وجبهه على اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار بعد سته ايام من
المفاوضات في بريتوريا بجنوب افريقيا
وتضمن الاتفاق ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
واعاده الخدمات الاساسيه اضافه الى انسحاب
القوات الاجنبيه مع الاتفاق على استمرار
المفاوضات السياسيه بين الجانبين في جولات
اخرى وتمت مراسم التوقيع بحضور الوساطه
الافريقيه وفرق المراقبين الدوليين وقد
وقع عن الاجانب الحكومه الاثيوبيه مستشار
رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي للامن القومي رضوان
الحسين ومن جانب جبهه المتحدث الاعلامي
باسمها جيتاتشو وقال رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبي هذه احمد انا الاتفاق مهم للغايه
في دفع اثيوبيا الى الامام على طريق
الاصلاحات التي بدات قبل اربع سنوات مشيرا
الى ان التزام حكومته بالسلام لا يزال
ثابته
في البرازيل اندلعت احتجاجاتهم من قبل
المعارضين فوز الرئيس اليسار المنتخب
الاولى دا سيلفا في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
وخساره الرئيس المنتهيه ولايته جايه
البولسونارو بياتي ذلك بعد ان التزم
بونسنارو الصمت
لثلاثه ايام منذ اعلان نتائج الانتخابات
قبل ان يؤكد التزامه بالدستور وقد اعلن
وزير الدوله المدنيه حصوله على تفويض من
الرئيس لبدء اجراءات التسليم والتسلم بين
الرئيسين
كما كان متوقعا لم يمر اعلان خساره الرئيس
المنتهيه ولايته جاي يرقصونارو دون اعتراض
انصاره الا ان شكل الاعتراضي وتاثيره كانه
هما المختلفين فسايقوا الشاحنات المؤيدون
في ناروتو اغلقوا اهم الطرقات في البلاد
وشلوا حركتها
اجرهم متظاهرون يرفعون مطارده وصفت
بانقلابيه
لكن الانقلاب حدث سابقا حينما اخرجوا الان
من السجن بغير وجه حق وفي الوقت الذي
تزامنت فيه الاحتجاجات مع صمت زعيمهم
ان كان خصمه السياسي المنتخب يتلقى
اتصالات التهنئه والاعتراف الدولي من
مختلف قاده العالم
وبعد صمت دام اكثر من 40 ساعه تحاشا خلاله
التعليق على نتائج الاقتراع القاب سونار
كلمه حملت مضامين عامه اكد فيها التزامه
بالدستور
وصفت كثيرا بغير الديمقراطيه لكنني اؤكد
التزام الكامله بالدستور كمواطن برازيلي و
كرئيس الجمهوريه ان وزير دوله المدنيه
فاعلن بدوره حصوله على تفويض من الرئيس
ببدا اجراءات التسلل والتسليم معتبر
اعترافا ضمينيا بخساره الانتخابات
مشهد يا فيه خبراء محاوله اخيره
لبورسونارو للحصول على ضمانات قبل مغادته
منصبه وقد ترك خلفه ازمات داخليه مركبه
وبلدا منقسما على نفسه صمت الرئيس لمده
ثلاثه ايام عن هذه التحركات التي ترفع
شعارات الانقلابيه ووضعتها في موقع الشك
خصوصا لعدم اعترافه بالهزيمه لكنه تنصل
اخيرا من هذه التحركات بعد لقائه قيادات
حزمه بعد الخطاب الرئاسي والاتهامات
للشرطه بالتواطئ استخدم المزيد من
التعزيزات الامنيه وتمكنت من فتح عدد من
الطرقات والمسالك تجاوب البعض لكن البعض
الاخر اص على الاستمراري في الاحتجاج
اسيل ولا ده سيلفا بعد محاوله تعطيل مرور
الاستحقاق الانتخابي بهدوء الى ان هذه
الاحتجاجات تشير بنظري مراقبين الى
التعقيدات التي قد تواجهها فتره الحكم
القادمه في البرازيل حسن مسعود الجزيره
سوبر
[موسيقى]
تعود الى مشهد الانتخابات الاسرائيليه حيث
بات معسكر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق
يعرف باسم شعب اليمين تسويه جاءت للتحالف
هي الذي يتم الحديث عن بنائه فبعد ان حصد
حزب اللكود اثنين وثلاثين مقابل في
الكنيست بنت تحالفه مع احزاب اليمنيه
ودينيه متطرفه تتوزع على ثلاثه تيارات
11 مقعدا وهو يصوت له عاده تيار اليهود
الشرقيين ويسع هؤلاء النهائي ما يعتبرونه
القيادا تاريخيا مارسته ضدهم النقب
اليهوديه الغربيه المهيمنه على الحياه
السياسيه في اسرائيل اما حزب اليه
حصد ثمانيه مقاعد في الكنيست فينتمي الى
تيار اليهود الحريدين وهو وهو متدينون
متذبطون منهم يهود من اصول شرقيه واخرون
من الاشكناز ذو الاصولي الغربي اما تيار
الاكثر الثالث والاكثر جدلفه وهو ما يعرف
بالصهيونيه الدينيه التي حصدت 14 مقعد
يتزحمها ي اسرائيل موتوريتش وعضو الكنيسه
الذي يعتبر
مؤسسه حركه كاخ المشهوره بالعداءه الشديد
للعرب استاذا روحيا له يضمه هذا التيار
مجموعه من احزاب والتيارات اليمين
الاستيطاني ويطرح برنامج يقوم على تعزيز
ما يصفها بالهويه اليهوديه لاسرائيل
نتنياهو الذي يبني هذا التحالف كما ذكرنا
هذا التحالف يتجه للعوده الى السلطه بعد
جولات المتكرره من الانتخابات لم تمكنه من
ضمان اغلبيه مستقره
والجوله الانتخابيه الحاليه هي الخامسه في
غضون اقل من اربع سنوات بعد انتخابات
ابريل من عام 2019 اخفق حزب اليهود وتحالف
ازرق ابيض في تشكيلي حكومه فتم حل الكنيست
والدعوه الى الانتخابات مبكرا بعد
انتخابات سبتمبر من العام ذاته فشله
الحسبان مجددا في تشكيل حكومه في الموعد
المحدد فاز النقود في انتخابات مارس من
عام 2020 فاتفق نتنياهو غانس على تشكيل
حكومه بالتناوب لكنها لم تصمت كثيرا جر
الخلافات
الموازنه فشلت اليه من جديد في تشكيل
حكومه
فوزي حزبه باعلى الاصوات في انتخابات مارس
من العام الماضي فاعللت احزاب المعارضه
لاستمرار ولايته الائتلاف الحكوميه الاخير
بعد تصديق الكنيست عليه
ارحب بضيفي في هذه الحصاد مهند مصطفى
ومدير مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات والخبير
في شان الاسرائيلي اهلا بك دكتور مهند كيف
نفهم كيف تفسر هذه العوده للي نتنياهو
متابع
قضائيا وهناك حتى اعضاء في اليمين لا
يحبون نظره ثانيه لشخصه وليس لانه من اللي
كود وبالتالي ما تفسير هذه العوده
يعني هذه العوده بعد محاولات في خمس دورات
انتخابيه لها الكثير من التفسيرات التفسير
الاول هو صعود وجهات اليمين المتطرف في
الشارع الاسرائيلي وايضا بسبب تماسك معسكر
نتنياهو المكون من اربع قوائم وتبعثوا
المعسكر المناهض له لتكون من حوادث ست سبع
قوائم
في معسكر المبعثره التي لم
تجاوز الحسيمه من حيث الاصوات المعسكرين
على نفس الاصوات ولكن تماسك معسكر اليمين
ووافع نسبه التصويت في صفوف القواعد
اليمنيه وبالذات اليمين المتطرف ساهم هذه
المره في حصول هذا المعسكر على حوالي 65
مقعده انجاز كبير جدا ولكن واحد من
الاسباب المركزيه لصعود هذا المعسكر معسكر
هو الصعود نجم الصهيونيه الدينيه وخاصه ال
سعود نجم همم
الذي خاطب المشاعر اليهوديه
الموجه الموجه ضد العرب من حيث انه اليهود
فقدوا فقدوا بيتهم فقدوا امنهم الشخصي
متهما بذلك العرب بالذات المجتمع العربي
في داخل اسرائيل
ايضا دكتور مهند في متعلق بهذه التركيبه
الجديده بهذه الواجهه الفاشيه كما يقول
الفلسطينيون نعم المجتمع الاسرائيلي اثبت
في هذه الانتخابات اولا انه توجهات وهي
توجهات اليمين وايضا اليمين المتطرف الذي
يريد الذي يفضل دوله يهوديه
على مركبها الديمقراطي وايضا اثبت هذه
الانتخابات انا مجتمع الاسرائيلي لا يريد
احزان عربيه مشاركه في اللعبه السياسيه
وفي النظام السياسي الاسرائيلي بمعنى ان
المجتمع الاسرائيلي الان هو متوجه في اغلب
يعني معسكر تنياهو اخذ 65
مركبات يمنيه في المعسكر والمناهض له
بمعنى ان اليمين في اسرائيل هو التيار
المهيمن في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
واليمين في اسرائيل واليمين اكثر منظم من
مكانها في السابق امام تباعثه المعسكر
المناهض له ولذلك المجتمع الاسرائيلي اثبت
في هذه
شكرا لك ادركنا الوقت الدكتور مهند مصطفى
مدير مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات والخبير في
الشان الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
بينما ان انهي الحصاد هذه الليله توقف
قليلا مع خبر اعلان اتفاق الوقفه اطلاق
النار في اثيوبيا قد يمر الخبر بشكل عابر
بالنسبه لكثيرين لكنه خبر مفرح لمن يعانون
نزاع ارغم اكثر مليونين شخص على النزوحي
عن ديارهم فيما تقول احصاءات بانه حصد
ارواح حتى الان نصف نحو نصف مليون شخص
ارقام محزنه لكن الاتفاق اليوم يدفعنا
لتفاؤل باتفاقات الاخرى توقف نزيف
الانسانيه في كل مكان
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]